欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一章节我们主要是讲一些关于店铺诊断的一些数据选择和它的一些判断方法
因为我们在做店铺诊断的时候是不是需要去判断一些数据或者是去看一些数据
那么我们要从哪个板块去看到底看怎么样的数据
这个对我们的一个判断的准确性是非常重要的
有利于我们快速找到具体的问题
第一个, 如果你要看人群跟国家的精准性, 如果是整个店铺, 我现在讲的是整个店铺的维度啊
如果店铺的维度的话, 你要看人群跟国家的准确性的时候, 我们在第一个在数据概览, 数据概览的时候, 我们点击一下我们的访客
访客数据下面对应的是国家的一个分布, 比如说你的是美国第一, 英国, 澳大利亚, 如果这些国家往下排
如果都是你的目标的国家的话说明你的整个店铺的人群国家是非常精准的
那么这个时候你就可以继续去提升它的转化就可以了
如果你想看询盘来自于哪些国家是否精准的话
那么我们就可以也是一样的点击询盘数据维度
找到看这个国家,看一下它的国家的排序
是不是你们目标国家想要的那些询盘
如果不是, 那么就说明我们的, 寻盘的质量可能会有所偏差, 需要我们去改善
第二个维度就是, 我们可以从访客画像里面, 访客画像现在是我们所说的就是, 买家参谋
买家参谋里面去看, 去看那些, TM, 寻盘, 还有订单维度, 选择这些订单维度, 选择30, 或者是90天的数据, 再去看对应的国家, 是不是你们目标的国家
如果是你们的目标国家占比最大的,就说明你们的这个国家非常精准
所以我们只需要去继续提升我们的转化率就可以了
第三个板块我们可以从流量参谋里面去看
流量参谋里面有一个流量的承接跟去向
那么这个里面有一个国家地域偏好,你去看一下
这些人是不是都是你们目标国家的
这个也是一样的,客户分析这里面
这个也可以, 你可以到时候自己去看一下, 这些板块都是有国家这个数据维度的, 所以我们通过这个板块就能够知道, 我们这个国家准不准, 我们整个整个店铺的国家是否精准, 这是对于国家的维度, 下面这个就是针对于产品的维度, 产品的维度就是词品这个板块, 比如说我们在产品分析里面, 是不是可以看得到,
高点击的产品以及点击的词是什么准不准是不是都可以从产品分析这里面去看吧
我们还可以把这些词拿去谷歌去搜索看看跟我们的这些产品的款式是否匹配
第二个板块我们还可以去引流关键词里面去关注高点击的词是否匹配我们的产品
因为我们这个引流关键词里面会有一个非常大的一个流量我们可以去看
同时我们也可以去看同行的点击是哪些词点的比较多这些点击值的搜索指数是怎么样的有些词点击高但是不代表他有很多搜索指数也就是他搜索指数可能很低如果这种情况的话我们也是不推广这类词的我们要去判断一下这些词是不是我们目标国家更加偏好搜索的那么这个怎么去判断呢把你的这些词拿去关键词指数
指数里面去搜索, 右下方有一个关于国家地域的一个搜索指数的一个占比码, 就能知道哪些国家更加偏好这个关键词, 第三个我们也提到过的关键指数, 可以直接去看新的产品, 或者是原始优化的产品, 我们去这里面找一些新的增长的词, 去发一些新的产品, 或者我们把这里面增长的词, 拿去优化我们产品的标题,
补充到我们产品标题中提升我们之前发布产品的一些产品的效果
最后面我们来总结一下我们要理解一些相关的一些概念
比如说买卖家分层, 买家分层, 局道分层, 赛道场景, 这些维度你要多去思考
卖家分层他是按照什么分的, 买家分层他又是按照什么分的
为什么他要分层,他的目的是什么
基本 它的目的就是为了精准匹配
提升它的转化和交易的效率
转化交易效率都是为了这个的
从这个是店铺的层级
那么从产品的层级呢
我们就要去思考
产品是不是一定要跟关键词相关
它是不是在不同的市场
它表现是不一样的
比如说产品在美国可能很热销
在英国可能就没什么效果
在东南亚可能也没什么效果
所以说产品跟市场它基本都是捆绑在一起的
那么这个时候我们就要去判断这个市场它偏好的产品人群国家这些
从这些维度去分析这个市场那么你就能够更加清晰了
那么流量的话其实就是磁和品的问题
你看搜索的时候是不是跟磁相关
推荐的时候是不是跟产品相关
是不是这推荐跟搜索都是流量
那么我们最终要解决的问题就是, 产品是否符合那个市场的需求, 产品的款式是否符合对应的国家的偏好
接着就是, 产品跟这些池的匹配度怎么样, 产品跟这些人群跟国家的匹配度怎么样, 池动转推广的精准度怎么样
这些都是决定着你的一个群盘的转化, 加上群盘的质量, 这两个维度
群盘的质量就决定着你的订单是否更加容易成交
所以我们平时如果你对知识点感觉到比较混乱的时候
我建议拿出一张纸或者是你在电脑上也可以用四位导图或者是文档去写一下你的思路
然后把重点的一些关键的节点写出来
那么就有利于你展开去思考了
最后面这个框架我们可以去重新梳理一下
按照对应的方法多去练习
然后形成一个记忆
也就是我们所学的这些内容
我们都不需要去使记硬背
我们应该是先去理解为主
你理解了
只要遵从我刚才讲的那个
曝光, 点击, 访客, 询盘, 订单
这一条主干线去思考
这一条主干线去拆分
你只需要记住这个主干线
那么你就能够衍生出非常多的方法
这些方法再结合你要去哪个板块看对应的数据然后去判断就能够知道它存在什么样的问题然后我们再去解决就可以了
那么这个就是关于我们整个店铺的一个诊断的一个框架跟思路跟方法以及店铺诊断的一些数据的选择和判断的方法
这个店铺诊断的这些技能是非常重要的都要重视起来多去练习多去操作
才能够真正的提升
我们这节课就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见